with so many storylines to wrap up and
character arcs to complete the final
season of Game of Thrones was bound to
make bold moves that not everyone agreed
with such was the case on the latest
episode of the fantasy drama the last of
the Starks which had fans sulking
stamping their feet and setting the
internet ablaze with criticism major
spoilers ahead the fourth episode of
season 8 started out strong picking up
after the jaw-dropping victory over the
night king and his white walker army at
the Battle of Winterfell to show the
survivors laughing carousing and
commending one another for their bravery
and strength
Daenerys made Gendry Lord of storms end
torment guzzle down wine like it was
going out of style and the Lannister
brothers goofed off playing a drinking
game with Brienne of Tarth that
eventually led to a steamy romance scene
sadly the merriment fizzled out as
quickly as it came and the last of the
Starks ended up disappointing tons of
diehard Game of Thrones fans my heart is
broken don't touch me
for starters many kicked up a fuss over
the increasingly strained dynamic
between Daenerys and Jon Snow who
recently revealed to his ladylove that
he's really her nephew and the rightful
heir to the Iron Throne some felt that
the tension between the two
Daenerys wants the Iron Throne more than
anything and firmly requests Jon not to
tell anyone about his true parentage
while Jon doesn't have any interest in
ruling the Seven Kingdoms and tells
Danny that he'll always bend the knee to
her has become unbearable one fan took
to Twitter to write that it's annoying
that Jon is letting his love for
Daenerys influence his decisions while
others said that the Dany John conflict
is frustrating because it seems a
marriage between the two would resolve
problems and allow them both to get what
they desire
Danny's recklessness and John's naivete
were also sore spots for some fans of
course that's just the tip of the
dragon's wing of problems fans had
viewers were heartbroken to see another
one of Daenerys dragons plummet to his
death this time ragel shot down by euron
greyjoy as Danny and her allied forces
stormed King's Landing one fan wrote on
Twitter that Regals death was a lazy
surprise tweeting like nobody saw the
massive fleet of ships that everybody
then saw immediately nobody thought the
scout when you know they have a massive
bleed of ships
another set in response they've written
themselves into a corner and have gotten
incredibly lazy sloppy with the story
they could have easily killed ray Gaul
because Danny saw the ships and in her
hubris went in charging not knowing
about all the arrows simple change much
more plausible wriggles gnarly demise
wasn't the only shocking death in the
episode as punishment for Daenerys not
giving up her crusade for the iron
throne and to send her a message about
what she'll do if she doesn't surrender
Cersei Lannister had the mountain behead
Danny's loyal advisor Musante who had
been taken prisoner when you're on in
his iron fleet ambushed Dany ships
unsurprisingly Masson Dee's murder sent
shockwaves through social media with
many stating that she deserved so much
better and others expressing distress
over the fact that her lover grey worm
is now living his worst nightmare the
indignation didn't stop there
more Thrones fans let it be known that
they were disappointed over John sending
his direwolf ghost north of the wall
without even patting his head to say
goodbye tyrion and varys contemplating
committing treason and considering
withdrawing their support for Dany in
favor of John after they learned who
John truly is and Jaime abandoning
Brienne and heading for Cersei and
King's Landing
shortly after the two knights shared
several intimate evenings together all
this anger and sadness over season 8
episode 4 of Game of Thrones has
resulted in a grim consequence the
episode is currently the second lowest
rated Thrones installment in history
based on Rotten Tomatoes reviews the
episode stands at a 61 percent approval
rating on the aggregator site coming in
only a few percentage points above the
disturbing season 5 episode unbowed
unbent unbroken which earned a score of
54% Game of Thrones has only two
episodes remaining in its entire run and
it's anyone's guess how the show is
going to bounce back from this perceived
low point especially now that Daenerys
is on the brink team Targaryen is down
to important members Danny's trusted
advisors could turn their backs on her
at any moment and Jamie is plotting
something big for the sake of viewers
well-being and in hopes that Thrones
will go out on a high notes we have our
fingers crossed that the upcoming
episode doesn't ruffle quite as many
feathers as this one did check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more Luke
videos about Game of Thrones are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]